we've been following the story of Donald
Trump's taxes for a very long time now
ever since he became the first major
party candidate in decades not to
release his tax returns when he was
running for president and it's not
legally required but it is tradition
Americans want to see them
polling during the campaign showed
around seventy five percent of Americans
wanted to see Donald Trump's taxes and
at a certain point Trump made the
calculation that what is in the taxes is
more damaging to him then the scrutiny
that he is receiving because he hasn't
released them and there's a few
possibilities about what might be in the
tax returns the least serious is just
that Trump is vain and he's not as rich
as he claims and that if he released his
tax returns that might be evident
although there's not even a guarantee
that that would be the case taxes
wouldn't necessarily expose exactly how
rich Donald Trump is but it might and
that would be sort of like the least
serious reason Trump doesn't want to
release them next is that his taxes
might expose criminality or tax evasion
or connections to the Russia probe there
are people who are saying Trump doesn't
want it to be public that he pays very
little taxes I disagree with that
because he bragged about how not paying
much in taxes makes him smart so it's
hard to imagine that a low effective tax
rate is what's keeping him from
releasing the taxes but now that we have
a democratically controlled house
there's the sort of most real
possibility of getting those returns in
a very long time and we've learned now
about a two-pronged scheme to prevent
the taxes from getting to House
Democrats and Trump's Treasury secretary
Stephen minuchin and his cronies are
front and center in trying to prevent
that from happening so there's two ways
that they are going to try to keep Trump
Trump's taxes private number one the
Treasury will argue a special team at
the Treasury will argue even though
Democrats shouldn't leak Trump's tax
returns it's very obvious that they're
going to if they get them and therefore
we are justified the Treasury will argue
in not handing them over to Democrats
that's one argument the second part
which is a more complicated one is that
as soon as they have the opportunity
the Treasury will or the people
appointed to handle this at the Treasury
will start making all sorts of arcane
legal arguments to prevent the release
to justify not releasing the Trump tax
returns and what they're basically
planning to do and it may work is just
create a really really long legal fight
into 2020 or beyond and just not full
flat out deny the release of the tax
returns but start to issue legal
challenges based on all sorts of sort of
arcane and antiquated rules that might
apply and hopefully just try to run out
the clock and next thing you know
Trump's not president anymore
the White House was asked about this
strategy and about the reports that the
White House and the Treasury are on the
same page in terms of what the strategy
is going to be to prevent these tax
returns from going public the White
House not surprisingly has not issued a
comment as of a few hours ago we just
have to zoom out here you know I talked
there I've said so many times over the
years we often are presented with a
story at some degree of detail or
granularity and sometimes we learn more
about it by zooming in and looking at
specific details but sometimes to really
get perspective on a story you have to
zoom out this is one of the cases where
you have to soot zoom out and ask the
question would anyone go to such extreme
lengths to hide something that would
just make them seem like they're being
transparent because if there was nothing
in the tax returns either for good
reasons
criminal reasons reasons of vanity and
Trump's wealth whatever if there were
not really good reasons that Trump sees
as good reasons not to release your tax
returns would you go to this much
trouble to keep them secret I don't
think that you would now you might call
me a contrarian on this issue I actually
don't think the taxes would reveal
criminality I think that the taxes might
give us some ideas of maybe places to
look but I think Moeller knows what
those places already
and I don't think the tax returns would
give us any provable evidence of
criminality I think that the taxes would
expose Trump is just not as rich as he
claims to be and ultimately this comes
down to Donald Trump's personality and
the cult of personality around Donald
Trump is being a billionaire however
many times over he claims to be at this
point but I think that that is actually
the reason why Trump doesn't want the
tax returns released I don't think we're
gonna get criminality even if they are
released and then the question on the
backend of all of this is does Moeller
already have them as great as that would
be I don't think that he does I actually
don't believe that Robert Moeller
already has the tax returns if you think
he does let me know how he got them hey
guys if you have a dog or a cat at home
or if you're looking for the perfect
gift for somebody in your life who has a
dog or a cat check out today's sponsor
pet box a subscription box where you can
get 50% off of your first box when you
click the link under this video and use
the coupon code Pakman when you sign up
for pet box you get an awesome selection
of premium toys all-natural treats for
your dog or cat delivered to your
doorstep every month and each month the
box is totally different it's actually
very affordable when you sign up for the
dog box you tell them what size dog you
have and you get a monthly variety of
true toys rawhides bags of dog treats
and a whole bunch of other cool items
catered to the size of your dog the cat
box comes with a ton of different stuff
every month like catnip toys snacks
things for them to scratch on and almost
everything that comes in each box is
made by small family-owned businesses I
just got the dog box for my dad's
English lab named Nemo who if you follow
me on Instagram you're probably familiar
with got a bunch of cool stuff including
pterodactyl treats and a true hide thing
obviously I don't know what all these
things are called and a toy which I know
my dad is just gonna love that noise and
the best thing about pet box is that
they give 10% of the proceeds to a
nonprofit called tender loving canines
which
helps provide service dogs to people
with autism and to vets with PTSD so
part of your purchase goes to a really
good cause and like I said you can get
half off your first box when you click
the link under this video and use the
coupon code Pakman that's PA que ma n